practically everyone in Saudi knows
Jennifer oh we know the Millennium
Village project has helped her become a
successful farmer I learned that you
just don't have to keep to one crop
because here people just used to do miss
and you do miss and they do miss but
then now for me when I started doing
farming through them Atlanta I could do
other crops as you can see in my farm in
addition to training the Millennium
Project gave Jennifer startup seeds and
fertilizer free of charge plus the
low-interest loan so she could build a
green house she now grows various fruits
and vegetables in addition to the maize
which also helps to minimize the risk of
a poor harvest plus fruit and veg are a
better earner than cereal grain I
believe if I do properly other farmers
will get to understand the importance of
doing agribusiness so that they just
don't do it for consumption but they
also do it
to get money Jennifer all we nose
operations have grown so much that she's
had to recruit four full-time employees
for the last two years she's been paying
for the seeds and fertilizer herself a
lot of other farmers however remain
dependent on donations from the
Millennium Project after weighing the
fresh produce is sent straight to the
market in Jennifer oh we nose case via
motorbike taxi
and the farmers here are far from the
only ones in salary benefiting from the
Millennium Project local schools had
been desperately under equipped with
many children often not attending at all
the Millennium Project saw the arrival
of textbooks and computers plus a free
school meal and the number of pupils has
now more than doubled in the last two
years explains the principal funding is
due to run out at the end of the year
however and with it those invaluable
meals to the money his school receives
from the Kenyan government is nowhere
near enough to cover costs I appealed
that they are given another period maybe
of three years to see as true so that
they can be able to accomplish their
vision they had this the situation
leaves much that's been achieved under
threat here at the market service center
local farmers like Jennifer oh we know
can sell their produce on consignment
another initiative set up by the
Millennium Project the center retains a
10 percent commission but the deal is
worth it she says not just financially
here you can see it's only one person
handing all that so not ten of us are
going to stay in the marketplace so it
takes only one person to sell and then
they also get to learn from one another
the advantage of being a group so they
will also benefit by learning from one
another how they can be able to make the
aggregate are much better for her the
Millennium Project has been a blessing
but some development experts claim it's
more of a curse the billions poured in
only served to create new dependencies
while leaving the respective sovereign
governments absolved of any
responsibility
even if funds do dry ups as the kenya
project director the project will keep
paying out dividends far beyond 2015 the
level of maintenance would be different
from what you've been doing but at the
back of my mind I'd be happy and saying
at least something is there and people
have been empowered they can now make
demands to the government because we
have devolved governments and demand for
services in some way hospice Jennifer oh
we know knows that not all farmers in
Saudi are doing as well as her in her
eyes success requires both the aid
programs and the right attitude as well
as a lot of discipline give me give me
you get lazy
you just sit you have nothing to look
forward to be doing as the day begins
but me I prepare in the morning as I
prepare I know I'm going to have a busy
day she's made the most of her chance
having gone from struggling farmer to
head of a profitable agribusiness